-There is a lot to go over,
so let's jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
Here we go.
♪♪
First up, Don Jr.
Today, he testified
in the Trump family's
civil fraud trial.
It was a big deal.
This has been years
in the making,
kind of like...
new music
from the Beatles.
They're releasing a new song
tomorrow using old recordings,
and A.I.
It's amazing.
This new technology
could really change the game.
Tonight was game 5
between Arizona and Texas,
featuring some of
the sport's greatest athletes.
They're in peak
physical condition,
mostly because
they don't eat
DiGiorno's new
Thanksgiving pizza.
It's got turkey,
creamy gravy, potatoes,
green beans, and cheese.
If you're eating one of these
on Thanksgiving,
clearly, your life has been
a huge disappointment.
Don Jr. is hoping
that if he does a good job,
his dad will take him outside
and finally say,
[ As Donald Trump ]
"Want to have a catch?"
[ Normal voice ]
The Diamondbacks and Rangers
are both trying
to win a championship,
and it all comes down
to who gets the outs
and who gets the runs.
And if you take down
that whole pie,
you're gonna be shouting,
"Help! I need somebody!"
or, "Get back!" you know?
Those are great songs.
So is "Here Comes the Sun."
Don Jr. took the stand,
but you won't be able to stand
once you finish
a turkey-covered pizza.
If you eat that thing,
your stomach will be
looking at you like,
"Pitch, please."
Both teams are trying to deliver
a title to their fans,
but it's -- it's not delivery,
it's DiGiorno.
In conclusion,
"Twist and Shout,"
strike three, you're out,
"Daddy, bail me out,"
gonna get gout?
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪